[Music]
listen we're in Tampa Florida right now
my good friend Harrison here
down here in Tampa Florida right now the
Buccaneers told me I could come out for
a tour I'm a huge football fan love the
Bucks love the cream simple jerseys this
in best jersey in the NFL okay and I get
here and I walk in and it's
you know I see my dad's name up on that
billboard it's crazy this is
man I'll tell you what this is awesome
thank you Tampa thank you Tampa Bay
Buccaneers go Bucks can't wait they told
me they're gonna let me fire the Cannons
I can't even wait I can't even wait
so we wanted since you were a real hell
yeah dude oh [__] yeah dude look at that
I'm wearing that on stage this weekend
[Music]
that is sick
dude
spell it rick either you got it right
now that's [__] love right there dude
that is sick
oh oh get the [__] out man that's too
much man that's gonna make me cry dude
my dad would [__] oh man
oh come on stop you did this on purpose
the slow walk and then the Thunder's
rolling that's Garth Brooks [__] Garth
Brooks where the bodies go oh man this
is sick dude get the [__] out of here oh
man thank you this is crazy dude I never
even met you before hugged you more and
I'm hugged any other man
I do want to know because I see listen I
see guys
like I'll see some players sell these
online
so you hope not to see that right so
ours are a little bit different than the
players so the players the top spins off
and there's a replica in Gold of the
stadium no underneath it yeah so like
basically where this seam is there's
twiss off and then it's basically this
Stadium because we were the first team
to win it home
until the Rams copied us yeah and then
there's the footballs on theirs are
basically big diamonds the words world
champions are in diamonds
um and then there are diamonds on the
side are a little different so they have
eight emerald cut diamonds on each side
that uh showcase the eight wins in a row
we had to get to win the Super Bowl that
year yeah I love the stories and these
things everybody's name on the side
theirs have some diamonds that go up and
down the sides too
the the inside trust loyalty respect was
Bruce aryan's saying for the team that
year one team won cause yeah it was
basically front office to players is
like there's one thing to do and it's
win the Super Bowl there is nothing else
yeah you didn't let him score a
touchdown
right yeah so the on the player one
there are 316 diamonds just on the top
to signify the score of 31-6
so just giving them a little kick for
for how many diamonds are in there oh
it's awesome that's well you ever get
anxious wearing it around not anymore it
fits it fits real good not I bought a
safe for this yeah um you don't wear it
daily do you or do you hear because this
is your job I mean where I'm around here
I wear it to every game not daily
because it's kind of like typing and
stuff and working with it's a little but
game days stretches oh hey everybody
yeah I feel like I adjust like wipe
sweat off my face like this now do you
have any relatives or anything that work
for other teams
um I know you guys have good friends
because yeah I love that you talk [__]
too to each other oh yeah all the other
teams just friends no no relatives no
relatives used to work in MLB you can
rub it in their face Thanksgiving I do
that with my aunt who used to work for
the Padres and
and she didn't get one
yeah okay get one this year
[Music]
that
hello the official
wait hold up
this is the official this is plastic
ware the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
guys
that's nice
Fork out of spoon we're out of spoon I
don't know who's who's on that as soon
as Tom Brady leaves the place falls
apart come on
[Music]
hell yeah look at that world champions
dude that's badass good for you guys
started out at ticket sales for the
raise
yeah so is this NFL role these are NFL
rules for your jersey look at this
you've got to have all the points of the
chin strap white only fastening face
mask attached look at that
it's wild the way they tailor those
shirts to their bodies like that so they
can't get a big RAB or I mean they have
to add them on and off
so each guy's got their own locker yeah
don't worry around the top of it the
history of the team kind of the big
names
Doug Williams an album Blazer the
original not the original but the last
owner
[Music]
oh this is crazy man
so are you guys aware of the um we wear
this this uniform this year I know you
brought the Jersey back but you're gonna
wear that helmet too the white one and
all that full uniform
it's live now so October 15th against
the Lions that's the first one yep
that's the only time we're wearing them
this year Oh I thought it was going to
be your home Jersey
so home is still the red with the the
flag is our main it's still three and
then we've got white jerseys and pewter
jerseys uh and then so it's only a one
week thing yeah this is October 15th but
fans are going to love it so much so
yeah so we made this is a shirt that we
just made so we made three t-shirts and
a crew neck sweatshirt and did like a
limited release and they sold out in a
day oh for sure so I mean not to bring
up the other team but that was what I
hated the original Oreo like not the
original the one that looked like an
oriole I hate it there was so there's no
character then everyone wanted the
cartoon one back boom they bring it back
yep it's like come on
regular home Unis regular home units
yeah right now right after we put up
that huge huge sign was it he went and
got I don't know you just the way you
know he just put a uh an Instagram story
up and it was just kind of like
you guys did yep I'm like man
just took a million
wow what does that cost to put that up
that one each one of those is about 12
Grand oh that's way less than I thought
well as long as you don't have to
replace the frame then it's another 12.
see John two years down here there's a
lot what how many seriously do you know
how many employees takes to make this
building go especially on a Sunday on a
Sunday
I think we we go over this like every
year because
the stadium people it's the concessions
people it's the merch people everybody
plus our staff plus you know players
coaches I think it's over 500 on a game
day
hell yeah shifts right above us now are
fans allowed to get on that thing during
the game or is that nope that's all just
Pirates just pirates only yeah we have
pirates on staff uh-huh who've roamed
the stadium and they're on the beat I
can't wait for the crowd to be like you
can't say Pirates anymore
Pirates are out like why
this is really well done
really well done it's kind of crazy
I could just see all the smells popping
out of here and stuff and is this your
first time on a pirate ship no
before we go out on the constellation in
Baltimore I don't know if I call it a
pirates of their Pirates
Oh yeah talk smack to opposing things so
they'd be walking by if you were in a
there's a guy who has a headset who's
just like he hides somewhere around here
so he'll be walking around just be like
yo that Raven Jersey's pretty ugly it's
like purple doesn't look good on you and
he'll just like the head will spin a
little bit great it'll be okay
I've never come up here
these are our cannons that actually fire
out so like what do you fire it's just
like CO2 blast
and they the smoke shoots out of these
and then Pirates throw Beats from up
here into the stand oh that's cool and
then this is all open to the public all
out in here so you can come and just
stand here there's a lot of people will
get 300 level tickets and come down like
party over here
if you're ever here for a game do not
come over here at halftime I cannot move
but when you're on here in the Cannons
fire the ground like the whole thing
shapes
it's kind of terrifying thank you I
don't want to keep any more of your time
here yes sounds good you gotta prep now
go relax watch this Tampa humidity off
Tampa [__] Florida how are you
goddammit
listen
this is only the sixth stop on this tour
I get here it's already my favorite by
far your [__] Buccaneers roll the
goddamn cream carpet out form I mean I
almost cried I don't even have a joke I
literally almost cry when I walked out I
was like what the [__] are you guys
doing
you've been awesome it's been awesome so
we went from like I walk out here and
it's my name all over your stadium and
stuff then we come in here and there was
a lady that passed out back there last
night and had to be carried out
so you know
samples wild you know what I mean
four people carrying around like a Civil
War veteran
here's the thing I didn't know it I
didn't know they told me after I was
like y'all had to call 9-1-1
they're like yeah we had to call 9-1-1
and I was like what
I saw how Tampa did a Tampa they were
like go get her ass out of here
they sat right behind they were like
dude that other bit I missed it I missed
it
oh I'm so excited to be here I haven't
been back here since I was a kid I've
never done stand up here it's first time
doing stand up here yeah it's been
awesome you got the best [__] club so
awesome you sold this place out Tampa
thank you very much
it's crazy
what's up everybody down here in Tampa
getting game day ready for the live and
a live tour all tickets are available at
ryansickler.com about to tear up Tampa
get the tickets Let's Go Go books
[Music]
[Applause]
funny show Ryan was absolutely
hysterical he's just so authentic love
the show Ryan it was fantastic love the
podcast love the Honeydew podcast so
good to see you live but I know I got to
sign up for the patreon you sign up for
a year you get over a month
foreign